they wouldn't about run it my dad would
have been trying to put their eyes up
with a half inch god knows and my mum
right behind him saying would you want
me to throw this bowl of water
now don't get him out run that up here
you ain't
it runs it can go faster than me and you
can run
so they wouldn't have got they wouldn't
have gone out
i'm lost for words i really have lots of
words that ain't normally me you know
how did how did your parents take it
then how did you and your dad take it
when you told them uh pretty
philosophical i was quite amazed at you
know and and then some to compound
should we say the situation
dad took it pretty philosophical as well
so
you know but it still don't account for
i mean there's all sorts of silly things
here like my old nan's last packet of
[ __ ] she
had four she gave up smoking 30 years
ago and
and i just want to get in there now and
there must be something in there they
must be saying i'll give them back there
must be
just one thing you know
do you think they'll ever come back to
see it like this i hope they don't
i wouldn't like them to see it like this
i'd give you best to keep the memories
you got aren't you